Just a heads up for listeners with sensitive ears. Today's episode includes a curse word that we are leaving unbleaped. You'll understand why, as you're listening, using that word is kind of the point of the whole show. So you've been warned. Enjoy. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm here today with producer Chris Barubei.
给听力敏感的听众提个醒。今天的节目包含一个我们没有消音的脏话。听完你就会明白原因，因为使用那个词正是这期节目的核心所在。所以，请做好心理准备。享受节目吧。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天和我在一起的是制作人克里斯·巴鲁贝。
Hey, Chris. Hey, Roman. So, Chris, what do you have for us today? Okay, today I want to talk to you about a subject that I think is going to make you really mad. Okay. Well, I have a pretty high baseline of mad right now, but I'm going to let you go ahead. Yeah, I feel like right now, most people I talk to have like a relatively high baseline of anger. So where would you say you are today, though? I think I'm having a pretty good day. Let's put a set of four.
嘿，克里斯。嘿，罗曼。那么，克里斯，今天你给我们带来了什么？好的，今天我想和你聊一个我觉得会让你非常生气的话题。好吧。嗯，我现在愤怒的基准线已经很高了，但我还是让你继续说吧。是啊，我觉得现在我交谈的大多数人，愤怒的基准线都相对较高。那么，你觉得你今天处于什么水平呢？我觉得我今天过得还不错。咱们定在四分吧。
Okay. Let's see how high we can get you by the end of this. So this is my experiment today. I want to see how high we can get you on the anger scale from one to ten. Okay. That sounds like a plan. So what's the story that's going to make me so mad? Okay, so Roman, I want you to think about smart devices. Okay, okay, I think you're on the right track, okay, to making me mad. Go ahead. Yeah, so let's just start. Think about all the devices that you own that used to be mostly analog.
好吧。看看节目结束时我们能把你激怒到什么程度。这就是我今天的实验。我想看看在一到十的愤怒量表上，我们能把你推到多高。好的。听起来是个计划。那么，是什么故事会让我这么生气呢？好的，罗曼，我想让你想想智能设备。好吧，好吧，我觉得你走对路了，好吧，确实快让我生气了。继续吧。是的，那我们就从头开始。想想你拥有的那些曾经主要是模拟的设备。
Today, they are now digital in some way. So can you think of some examples in your life. Well, I can think of one very obvious example that drives me crazy. I have a smart thermostat in my house. It came with the house. I did not install it. And I live in the Bay Area, so I don't need heat a lot. But every time I need to turn it on, which is like a few times a year, the smart thermostat is like disconnected from the heater.
今天，它们在某种程度上已经数字化了。那么你能想到生活中一些例子吗？嗯，我能想到一个非常明显的例子，让我抓狂。我家里有一个智能恒温器。它是随房子自带的。我没有安装它。而且我住在湾区，所以我不需要太多的暖气。但每次我需要打开它时，也就是一年几次，这个智能恒温器总是和加热器断开连接。
And for some reason, unknown reason, I cannot make sense of it. And all I want is just an old-fashioned brass, round Honeywell thermostat, old-fashioned analog thermostat that can just turn on and set it to a temperature and turn it off when I don't need it instead of this other thing that drives me absolutely crazy. So, Roman, this is a pretty common complaint, what you're saying, right? We all have these devices that have some kind of a smart component. They're supposed to make things convenient in our lives. But in fact, they are making things really frustrating. Like, why does my fridge need to be smart and talk to me, right? Today, though, we're going to talk about how this phenomenon, it could be more than just annoying for a lot of people.
而且出于某种原因，未知的原因，我无法理解它。我想要的只是一个老式的黄铜圆形霍尼韦尔恒温器，那种老式的模拟恒温器，只要能打开、设定温度，不需要时关掉就行，而不是这个让我绝对抓狂的东西。所以，罗曼，你说的这是一种很常见的抱怨，对吧？我们都有这些带有某种智能组件的设备。它们本应让我们的生活更方便。但事实上，它们让事情变得非常令人沮丧。比如，为什么我的冰箱需要智能并和我对话，对吧？不过今天，我们要谈谈这种现象，对很多人来说，它可能不仅仅是令人讨厌。
Because there are times when the digitization of pretty much everything is actively making people's lives worse. And so to demonstrate this point, I want to talk to you about the design of tractors. Okay. Well, I mean, you strike me as a city kid, Chris. So, like, what do you know about tractors? Very little, if I'm being honest. I know there is a company called John Deere that makes tractors and they have green hats. I assume there was probably a guy named John Deere at some point in the past.
因为在很多时候，几乎所有事物的数字化都在积极地让人们的生活变得更糟。为了证明这一点，我想和你谈谈拖拉机的设计。好吧，我的意思是，你给我的印象是个城市孩子，克里斯。所以，你对拖拉机了解多少？说实话，了解很少。我知道有一家叫约翰迪尔的公司生产拖拉机，他们戴着绿色的帽子。我假设过去某个时候可能有一个叫约翰迪尔的人。
You would assume? Not too much else, but I learned quite a bit for this story. So there's one thing that's been vexing farmers. that really surprised me, and that is the software in their tractors. So like a lot of things, modern tractors are now run by a computer operating system, and one of the farmers who's not happy with the software in his tractor is a guy I spoke to for this story, a farmer in Missouri named Jared Wilson. On my lineage, I'm at least a seventh generation farmer on my father's side,
你会这么假设？没别的了，但我为这个故事学到了不少。有一件事一直困扰着农民，这让我非常惊讶，那就是他们拖拉机里的软件。像很多东西一样，现代拖拉机现在由计算机操作系统运行，而其中一位对拖拉机软件不满的农民，就是我为这个故事采访的人，一位住在密苏里州的农民，名叫贾里德·威尔逊。在我的家族血统中，我至少是父亲那边的第七代农民，
so we've been doing this for a while. So Jared runs a family farm. You know, he's deep in the trenches of this world, and he told me something I did not really know about farming equipment. Tractors, harvester, spraying machines, you know, all of these vehicles that are critical to farming. Today, for the most part, they are run by computers. You know, in the 90s, we didn't have a lot of electronic control units on these machines. Mechanical fuel pumps.
所以我们做这一行已经很久了。所以贾里德经营着一个家庭农场。你知道，他深陷这个领域，他告诉我一些我不太了解的农业设备知识。拖拉机、收割机、喷洒机，你知道，所有这些对农业至关重要的车辆。今天，在很大程度上，它们是由计算机运行的。你知道，在90年代，这些机器上没有太多的电子控制单元。机械燃油泵。
Everything was mechanical. So you touch something and it has linkage and it's controlling something mechanical. And now in these machines, when you touch something, everything is electrical. over some system, electric over hydraulic, if you will, electric over engine controls. And that means that there's software that you're dealing with. I am sure if you're a farmer, this is all incredibly obvious stuff, but, you know, this was a surprise to me. Like, it's the same thing with a lot of cars now, where functions that used to be mechanical, they are now all run by an operating system. And my car, you know, gives me a driving score, for example, which is very,
一切都是机械的。所以你触碰某样东西，它有联动装置，控制着机械部件。而现在在这些机器里，当你触碰某样东西时，一切都是电控的。通过某种系统，如果你愿意的话，电控液压，电控发动机控制。这意味着你正在处理软件。我相信如果你是个农民，这些都是极其显而易见的事情，但是，你知道，这对我来说是个惊喜。就像现在很多汽车一样，过去是机械的功能，现在全由操作系统运行。比如我的车，你知道，会给我一个驾驶评分，这非常，
very, very annoying. But for the most part, Jared told me this digitization of the tractor, it's a really positive thing. Like, in lots of ways, these controls make his job a lot easier. One of the simplest things that comes to mind is auto steer, right? These tractors, we can create lines in the field and they'll drive themselves. And when you're on a machine for 20 hours and you don't have to steer it, you're in a lot better shape when you get off of it than you are hand-driving the machine. Yeah. I mean, that sounds completely arduous to be a driver for 20 hours in something. We have to pay attention to every moment of those 20 hours.
非常，非常烦人。但在很大程度上，贾里德告诉我，拖拉机的这种数字化，是一件非常积极的事情。比如，在很多方面，这些控制装置让他的工作轻松多了。最简单的事情之一就是自动转向，对吧？这些拖拉机，我们可以在田地里创建线路，它们会自己驾驶。当你在一台机器上待了20个小时，而不需要亲自转向，当你下来时，你的状态比手动驾驶机器要好得多。是的。我的意思是，作为驾驶员在某种东西上待20个小时听起来非常艰苦。我们必须在那20个小时的每一刻都保持专注。
But I'm anticipating here that there are some negative aspects to this, too. Yes, there are some drawbacks. So Jared told me if there's a problem with the tractor, sometimes the software will just slow down the tractor's horsepower. If anything is not working correctly on the emission system, if you have a sensor, for instance, that has failed or malfunctioned, it won't perform the necessary emissions operations to satisfy the system, and it will do something called a de-rate of the machine. So at de-rating, this is when the software basically makes the tractor unusable.
但我预感到这里面也有一些负面影响。是的，确实有一些缺点。所以贾里德告诉我，如果拖拉机出了问题，有时软件会直接降低拖拉机的马力。如果排放系统有任何工作不正常，比如你有一个传感器失效或故障，它就不会执行满足系统所需的排放操作，它会执行一种叫做机器降级的操作。所以降级，这就是软件基本上让拖拉机无法使用的时候。
Like, it slows down the horsepower so much. You cannot use the tractor to do farming. That sounds so incredibly annoying. But I would assume that this software was doing this for some kind of good reason, like for a safety reason. Right. So there could be safety reasons for doing this, or smaller issues, like a sensor isn't working on the tractor. And Jared gave me this example from his life
比如，它把马力降低得太多了。你无法使用拖拉机进行耕作。这听起来太令人恼火了。但我会假设这个软件这样做是有某种正当理由的，比如出于安全原因。对。所以这样做可能有安全原因，或者是一些小问题，比如拖拉机上的传感器坏了。贾里德给了我一个他生活中的例子，
where he had a problem with the tractor and the operating system slowed it down, but it didn't tell him what was wrong. You know, the terminals inside of the machine might give you an error code, but very rarely does that error code actually tell you what's wrong. You have to have an external piece of software
他遇到了拖拉机的问题，操作系统降低了它的速度，但它没有告诉他出了什么问题。你知道，机器内部的终端可能会给你一个错误代码，但那个错误代码很少真正告诉你出了什么问题。你必须有一个外部软件
to plug into the machine to figure it out. So when this happened to Jared, he was faced with a choice, right? He could either spend a lot of time trying to figure out the problem, you know, waste a day doing that. Or he could do the much easier thing, which was call out a technician. But according to Jared, that's also kind of a pain. So I was forced to call the dealership out.
插入机器才能弄清楚。所以当这种情况发生在贾里德身上时，他面临一个选择，对吧？他要么花很多时间试图找出问题，你知道，浪费一天时间做这件事。要么他可以做更简单的事情，那就是叫技术员来。但据贾里德说，那也很麻烦。所以我被迫叫了经销商。
They came out and replaced, I think, one of the delta pressure sensors. And that didn't end up fixing the problem. But the logistics of that mean that the technician comes out. You may have to wait a day or two before there's a technician available. And losing a couple of days during the course. growing season, that's a total disaster, because Jared told me, losing a day can cost him a ton of money. The soybeans, we'd had a dry ear, and you could stand in the field and you could hear the pods opening and the soybeans hitting the ground. So you can imagine how sick to your stomach that makes you.
他们过来更换了，我想，其中一个压力传感器。但这并没有解决问题。但其中的物流意味着技术员要过来。你可能得等上一两天才能有技术员有空。而在生长季节损失几天，那简直是一场灾难，因为贾里德告诉我，损失一天可能会让他损失一大笔钱。大豆，我们经历了一个干旱的年份，你可以站在田里，听到豆荚裂开，大豆掉在地上的声音。所以你可以想象这让他有多心痛。
There's no way to reclaim those once they fall on the ground. That's just lost revenue that's just gone. And it's difficult to convey how frustrating that is when you're sitting on your hands and your crop is literally falling on the ground. And you don't have the ability to do anything about it. Jared didn't have a guess about how much these kinds of delays have cost him. But in 2023, the public interest research group, so they're this advocacy group. They estimated downtime for farmers caused by these repair delays cost them about $3 billion that year. And this is at a time when farmers are facing.
一旦它们掉在地上，就没法收回了。那只是损失的收入，就这样没了。当你束手无策，而你的庄稼正实实在在地掉在地上时，很难表达那种沮丧感。你对此无能为力。贾里德没有猜测这些延误让他损失了多少钱。但在2023年，公共利益研究小组，也就是那个倡导组织。他们估计，这些维修延误导致的农民停工在那一年让他们损失了约30亿美元。而这正是在农民面临各种挑战的时候，
all sorts of challenges, like unpredictable weather, tariffs, and then on top of that, you have to figure out these software problems. So the stakes are really, really high for somebody like Jared. The reality is that the costs of these things have
比如不可预测的天气、关税，除此之外，你还得解决这些软件问题。所以对于像贾里德这样的人来说，风险真的非常非常高。现实情况是，这些东西的成本已经
eliminated a lot of the margin potential that comes from the savings because we're just passing it back out to the manufacturer. So, Roman, with this in mind, where are you at on the anger scale? Now I'm a six. This is sounding more and more like the plight of every modern consumer or user of modern devices. It's really, really infuriating.
抵消了节省带来的大部分利润潜力，因为我们只是把钱又交回给了制造商。所以，罗曼，考虑到这一点，你的愤怒量表在什么位置？现在我是六分。这听起来越来越像每个现代消费者或现代设备用户面临的困境。这真的，真的让人愤怒。
Yeah, like if you own a car, if you own a cell phone, if you own a printer, right? You kind of had the same problems. And frankly, the software is making all of these things, if you will pardon my language, shittier for us as consumers. Because basically with the software, often you cannot fix them unless you go back to the manufacturer. And I started getting interested in this whole subject because of one of my favorite writers. Hi, I'm Corey Doctoro. I'm a novelist and activist and a journalist. So listeners at the show may be aware of Corey's work. You know, he's a sci-fi writer. And hey, here is a fun fact about Cory Doctoro. We can reveal, perhaps, that you and I are like all the best Americans, Canadian. You had to squeeze it in there. Roman, we are everywhere. So anyway, lately, Corey's been out there popularizing this one big idea that he's had. So it's a word. word that he coined, that seems to be capturing a lot of what's going wrong in modern society right now. And that word is in shittification. Roman, have you heard the word in shittification?
是的，就像如果你拥有一辆车，如果你拥有一部手机，如果你拥有一台打印机，对吧？你基本上有同样的问题。坦率地说，软件让所有这些东西，请原谅我的用词，对我们消费者来说变得更烂了。因为基本上有了软件，通常除非你回到制造商那里，否则你无法修复它们。我开始对这个主题感兴趣是因为我最喜欢的作家之一。嗨，我是科里·多克托罗。我是一位小说家、活动家和记者。所以节目的听众可能了解科里的作品。你知道，他是一位科幻作家。嘿，这里有一个关于科里·多克托罗的趣事。我们或许可以透露，你和我一样，像所有最好的美国人一样，是加拿大人。你非得把它塞进去。罗曼，我们无处不在。所以总之，最近，科里一直在推广他提出的这个大想法。这是一个词。一个他创造的词，似乎捕捉到了当今现代社会正在发生的大部分错误。那个词就是“烂化”（enshittification）。罗曼，你听说过“烂化”这个词吗？
I have. I'm also a big fan of Cory Dr. O. And what I know of it is that this is the idea that, you know, kind of everything on the internet is getting worse. Yeah. So that's a part of it. And there's actually a little bit more to it than that. It's a way to talk about platform collapse, platform decay. It describes this three-stage process where you have platforms that start off being good to their end users, but are also finding a way to lock those end users in. And then having locked them in, it makes things worse for them in order to make things better for business customers. So let's just lay this out with an example. You're on Facebook. You are part of a Facebook group that likes something very, very niche, right? Like, let's say baseball cards from the 1980s,
我听说过。我也是科里·多克托罗的忠实粉丝。据我所知，这个想法是，你知道，互联网上的所有东西都在变糟。是的。所以这是其中的一部分。实际上它还有更多含义。这是一种谈论平台崩溃、平台衰退的方式。它描述了一个三阶段的过程，即平台最初对终端用户很好，但同时也找到了锁定这些终端用户的方法。然后一旦锁定他们，为了让商业客户受益，它就会让终端用户的情况变得更糟。让我们用一个例子来说明。你在Facebook上。你是Facebook上一个喜欢非常非常小众事物的群组的成员，对吧？比如，假设是1980年代的棒球卡，
just to use an example of a hobby someone might have, right? I'm not saying that is me. Someone has this hobby, though. Got it. The first step is Facebook sets up the infrastructure for you to meet lots of new people, right? So you're finding other fans of 80s baseball cards. You're all becoming friends. You're building up this community.
只是为了用一个某人可能有的爱好作为例子，对吧？我不是说那是我。不过确实有人有这个爱好。明白了。第一步是Facebook为你建立了结识许多新朋友的基础设施，对吧？所以你找到了其他80年代棒球卡的粉丝。你们都成了朋友。你们正在建立这个社区。
But then you cannot leave. Like, maybe the platform is buying up all the competition, right? So there's nowhere else to go. Or they make it hard to transport your group somewhere else. and maybe like people don't want to leave because you have years of thrilling 80s baseball card conversations built up. And then you get stuck, right? So if you leave, you're going to lose all of these friends that you've built up and you become locked in. And that's when the big companies will start to make things shittier.
但后来你无法离开。比如，也许平台正在收购所有竞争对手，对吧？所以没别的地方可去了。或者他们让你很难把你的群组转移到别处。也许人们不想离开，因为你们已经建立了多年关于80年代棒球卡的激动人心的对话。然后你就被困住了，对吧？所以如果你离开，你就会失去所有这些你建立起来的朋友，你就被锁定了。而这就是大公司开始让事情变得更烂的时候。
They in shittify. And instead of serving the users, they will serve businesses, right? They'll make things worse for you. They will sell your private data. They will let the platform become filled with these kind of spammy, annoy. annoying ads that you can't get rid of. The value is just hoovered up by the platform and given to its shareholders and its executives, even as the platform just turns into a pile of shit.
他们进行“烂化”。他们不再服务于用户，而是服务于企业，对吧？他们会让你的体验变差。他们会出售你的私人数据。他们会让平台充斥着那种你无法摆脱的垃圾广告。价值被平台吸走，分给了股东和高管，即使平台本身变成了一堆垃圾。
And I think a lot of us can recognize that pattern. Okay. That description makes a lot of sense to me. So here's the other thing with Corey's argument. He says, in shitification, it is not exclusive to being online, you know, on Facebook, on Google, wherever. It can also affect things in the physical tactile world, such as all of our smart devices. Okay, so how does that work? Well, Corey says this same principle applies to basically all of our smart devices, right, including our cars, our smart fridges, our tractors, stuff that just wasn't previously digital.
我想我们很多人都能认出这种模式。好的。那个描述对我来说很有道理。所以科里的论点还有一点。他说，“烂化”并不局限于在线，你知道，在Facebook上，在谷歌上，无论哪里。它也会影响物理触觉世界中的事物，比如我们所有的智能设备。好的，那它是怎么运作的？嗯，科里说同样的原则基本上适用于我们所有的智能设备，对吧？包括我们的汽车、智能冰箱、拖拉机，那些以前不是数字化的东西。
Willing Gibson, the science fiction writer, coined the term cyberspace. He's quite a profit. And in one of his books, he has this line, cyberspace is averting. So turning inside out. And what he means is that, like, reality is being infected with digital stuff. and digitization is becoming a feature of things that weren't digital before. Everything's just becoming a computer in a fancy case. Let's just talk about how many of our devices today rely on computers and rely on the internet. So how many smart devices would you estimate you have in your home right now? Uh, 20?
科幻作家威廉·吉布森创造了“赛博空间”（cyberspace）这个词。他真是一位先知。在他的书中有一行字：赛博空间正在“翻转”（averting）。也就是由内而外地翻转。他的意思是，现实正在被数字事物感染。数字化正在成为以前不是数字化的事物的特征。一切都只是变成了一个装在漂亮外壳里的计算机。让我们谈谈今天我们有多少设备依赖计算机和互联网。那么你估计你家里现在有多少智能设备？呃，20个？
Possibly. That's pretty average, if that's right. So according to this survey I found from 2023, the average American House hold has about 21 connected devices. So that means devices that are connected to the internet. Wow. Wow. That is way too high. I can already think of the ones that I wish I could eliminate from my house right now. Oh, 100%. And the thing with all of these smart devices is that it makes it a lot easier for a company that makes this device to lock you in, right? So the first step into justification, it's locking you in because if something is a smart device, the manufacturer has
可能吧。如果那是真的，那相当平均。根据我找到的2023年的一项调查，普通美国家庭大约有21个联网设备。这意味着连接到互联网的设备。哇。哇。那太高了。我已经能想到我现在就想从家里淘汰掉的那些设备了。哦，百分之百。所有这些智能设备的问题在于，它让制造这些设备的公司更容易锁定你，对吧？所以进入“烂化”的第一步，就是锁定你，因为如果某样东西是智能设备，制造商就有
quite a bit of leeway. Let's go back to tractors, where we started this whole episode. Corey Doctro says they are a prime example of this. Since Roman times, farmers have fixed their own gear because when the storm is coming and you need to get the crops in, you can't wait for someone else to come and fix your stuff. According to Jared, you know, back in the 90s, the tractor is mostly mechanical, right? and if you wanted to replace a part or fix something in the tractor, it was a pretty straightforward process. You would go down to your local John Deere dealership,
相当大的余地。让我们回到拖拉机，我们这期节目的起点。科里·多克托罗说它们是这方面的一个典型例子。自罗曼时代以来，农民们一直自己修理装备，因为当风暴来临时，你需要收割庄稼，你不能等别人来修理你的东西。据贾里德说，你知道，在90年代，拖拉机主要是机械的，对吧？如果你想更换零件或修理拖拉机里的东西，这是一个相当直接的过程。你会去当地的约翰迪尔经销商那里，
and, you know, that was owned by a guy who lived down the road. I remember as a kid going with my dad, and if you had a complaint, you went to Leland Deems, and he might take you back in the shop and ask what was going on. He wanted a customer to be satisfied, and he knew that if he didn't, you'd go down the road to the next dealership the next time you were buying a piece of equipment.
而且，你知道，那是由一个住在路那头的家伙拥有的。我记得小时候和我爸爸一起去，如果你有抱怨，你就去找利兰·迪姆斯，他可能会带你去车间后面问发生了什么事。他希望客户满意，他知道如果他不这样做，下次你买设备时就会去路那头的下一家经销商那里。
You know, say you have a problem with a wire, or you need a replacement part, you go to Leland Deems, right? And if you're not happy with Leland Deems, you could go to another dealership. Or maybe you go to an independent repair person who's somewhere down the road, right? They'd hook you up and then you would go about your day. But in Jared's experience, a few times this has happened. He received the error code, didn't get a lot of information from the operating system. And without much to go on, he went straight to John Deere.
你知道，假设你的电线出了问题，或者你需要更换零件，你去找利兰·迪姆斯，对吧？如果你对利兰·迪姆斯不满意，你可以去另一家经销商。或者也许你去找路那头的独立维修人员，对吧？他们会帮你修好，然后你就可以继续你的一天了。但在贾里德的经历中，这种情况发生过几次。他收到了错误代码，没有从操作系统得到太多信息。在没有太多线索的情况下，他直接去找了约翰迪尔。
And at that point, John Deere holds all the cards, right? Because to restart the tractor, Jared needed a technician who knows how to access the tractor's computer. And then at that point, he had to pay that person to come and check it out. The farmers still mostly fix their tractors. They get the part they put it in and so on. It's their farmers. They don't want to fix their stuff. But it doesn't work.
在那一点上，约翰迪尔掌握了所有主动权，对吧？因为要重启拖拉机，贾里德需要一个知道如何访问拖拉机计算机的技术员。然后在那一点上，他必须付钱让人过来检查。农民们仍然主要修理他们的拖拉机。他们拿到零件，装上去等等。他们是农民。他们不想修理他们的东西。但它不工作。
It doesn't work until you get a service call and pay $200 for someone to show up and type the unlock code into your tractor's keyboard. As a farmer, it's not as easy as you go to the repair shop down the road. they fix something for you. Because usually independent repair places, they don't have the tools that John Deere corporate has. Because John Deere is not making that stuff available unless the repair person is paying a big fee. My independent mechanic, I called him up and he said he didn't have the tools to do that because they cost $6,000. So because John Deere makes it expensive for independent repair shops to fix John Deere products, as a consumer, you're stuck paying whatever John Deere is charging. And this is a big way you get locked in. It's replacement parts. So if Jared buys a
它不工作，直到你叫了服务电话并支付200美元让人过来，在你的拖拉机键盘上输入解锁码。作为农民，这不像你去路那头的维修店那么容易。他们为你修理东西。因为通常独立维修店没有约翰迪尔公司拥有的工具。因为除非维修人员支付一大笔费用，否则约翰迪尔不会提供这些东西。我的独立机械师，我给他打电话，他说他没有工具做那个，因为它们要6000美元。所以因为约翰迪尔让独立维修店修理约翰迪尔产品变得昂贵，作为消费者，你只能支付约翰迪尔收取的任何费用。这是你被锁定的一个重要方式。那就是更换零件。所以如果贾里德买了一个
replacement part, he probably needs to buy it from John Deere because he doesn't have a lot of options for where else you can buy the thing. I'm getting very angry, Chris. This is very upsetting to me. Keep some room. Okay. Keep some room. We need a ceiling that we can achieve later on in the episode. You're going to get there. So Roman, in the past, farmers could actually buy a generic replacement part, right? Like a part that was built by somebody who isn't John Deere. But today, with the software, John Deere does this trick called parts pairing.
更换零件，他可能需要从约翰迪尔购买，因为他在哪里还能买到这个东西方面没有太多选择。我变得非常生气，克里斯。这让我非常不安。留点余地。好的。留点余地。我们需要一个我们在节目后面可以达到的上限。你会达到的。所以罗曼，过去，农民实际上可以买到通用的更换零件，对吧？比如一个不是由约翰迪尔制造的零件。但今天，有了软件，约翰迪尔玩了一个叫“零件配对”（parts pairing）的把戏。
So if you want to replace a drill, something like that, certain parts are not going to work unless they are compatible with John Deere's software. So that's parts pairing. And this is related to this really important concept called interoperability. I've definitely heard that term before. But what does it actually mean here?
所以如果你想更换一个钻头，类似的东西，某些零件如果不与约翰迪尔的软件兼容，就不会工作。这就是零件配对。这与一个非常重要的概念有关，叫做“互操作性”（interoperability）。我肯定以前听过这个词。但在这里它到底是什么意思？
Basically, interoperability is whether two things can work together, right? So if you have shoes and shoelaces, if the laces are the right size, they fit inside the shoe, those two things are interoperable. And in a digital context, two things are interoperable if they can talk to each other. And parts pairing makes that difficult because with tractors, you know, you can buy some generic parts that is cheaper than what John Deere is selling, but it won't necessarily work because John Deere software might lock it out. So these two things are not interoperable. And tractors are kind of the tip of the iceberg here, because this kind of thing can happen with all of our smart devices. And Corey brought up this example to me, which is printers. Your printer company says, we don't like it when you use third-party ink.
基本上，互操作性是指两样东西是否能一起工作，对吧？所以如果你有鞋子和鞋带，如果鞋带尺寸合适，它们能装进鞋子里，这两样东西就是互操作的。在数字环境中，如果两样东西能互相交流，它们就是互操作的。而零件配对让这变得困难，因为对于拖拉机，你知道，你可以买一些比约翰迪尔卖的便宜的通用零件，但它们不一定会工作，因为约翰迪尔的软件可能会锁定它们。所以这两样东西是不互操作的。而拖拉机在这里只是冰山一角，因为这种事情可能发生在所有的智能设备上。科里向我提到了这个例子，也就是打印机。你的打印机公司说，我们不喜欢你使用第三方墨水。
And so we're going to block third-party ink installation. Once we do that, we're going to charge you more for the ink that comes from HP or Epson or whatever. It's not that your printer can't run that program. It's that your printer has been designed to reject that program to say no. Inks now $10,000 a gallons. The most expensive fluid you can buy is a civilian without a special license. It costs more to print your grocery list than it would if you printed it with the semen of a Kentucky Derby-winning stallion. This is why I like Corey.
所以我们要阻止第三方墨水的安装。一旦我们这样做，我们就会向你收取更多来自惠普或爱普生等的墨水费用。并不是你的打印机不能运行那个程序。而是你的打印机被设计成拒绝那个程序，说不。墨水现在一加仑1万美元。这是平民在没有特殊许可的情况下能买到的最昂贵的液体。打印你的购物清单的成本比你用肯塔基德比冠军种马的精液打印的成本还要高。这就是我喜欢科里的原因。
He paints some word pictures. He puts a little mustard on the fastball. And by the way, I did. I look this up. This is a bit of an exaggeration. Like the Kentucky Derby winning semen is very expensive. It's worth a lot of money. But printer is expensive too, right?
他描绘了一些文字画面。他在快球上加了一点芥末。顺便说一句，我确实查过了。这有点夸张。比如肯塔基德比冠军的精液非常昂贵。它值很多钱。但打印机也很贵，对吧？
It costs like thousands of dollars a gallon, which is so much money. I mean, shitty is the right word for it. I mean, it's awful. Yeah, it's really shitty. And it's also a big problem with powered wheelchairs. You have smart fridges. You have ventilators. One more example is about the device you are probably listening to this on right now.
它每加仑要花费几千美元，这真是太多钱了。我的意思是，“烂”是形容它的正确词汇。我的意思是，这太糟糕了。是的，这真的很烂。而且这也是电动轮椅的一个大问题。你有智能冰箱。你有呼吸机。还有一个例子是关于你现在可能正在用来听这个节目的设备。
So let's say you have an iPhone. I'm sure you've experienced some version of this as someone who owns an iPhone. If you need to repair an iPhone, there's lots of cases where you cannot get a third-party replacement part. Those will just not be interoperable with an Apple device.
所以假设你有一部iPhone。我相信作为iPhone用户，你经历过这种版本的体验。如果你需要修理iPhone，有很多情况下你无法获得第三方更换零件。它们只是无法与苹果设备互操作。
So Apple urges you to buy an Apple replacement part and then go to the Apple store or go to an Apple authorized repair person. Tim Cook in 2019 wrote a letter to his investors at the start of the year we said our biggest risk is that our customers repair phones
所以苹果敦促你购买苹果更换零件，然后去苹果商店或去苹果授权的维修人员那里。蒂姆·库克在2019年给他的投资者写了一封信，在年初我们说我们最大的风险是我们的客户修理手机
instead of buying new ones, that they like their phones. They work fine. And so when they break, they don't just get a new one. Apple uniquely among manufacturers, when you trade a phone in, sends it to be shredded so that the parts can't be harvested to be used in a repair. So to recap, this is the inshittification of things, right? You buy something that has software in it. The software makes it hard to get the thing repaired by some third party. You have to go to the manufacturer and they will jack up the price, right?
而不是购买新手机，他们喜欢他们的手机。它们工作得很好。所以当它们坏了时，他们不会直接买新的。苹果在制造商中独树一帜，当你以旧换新时，它会把手机送去粉碎，这样零件就不能被回收用于维修。所以总结一下，这就是事物的“烂化”，对吧？你买了一个带有软件的东西。软件让你很难让第三方修理这个东西。你必须去找制造商，他们会抬高价格，对吧？
and perhaps they don't let you use third-party parts, so they're just profiting off people because we're stuck, right? We have this stuckness going on. So this is a vicious cycle. So, Roman, now that I have gone through the problem of incitification with you, where would you say your anger level is at as of now? Let's go for a nine. I'm a nine.
也许他们不让你使用第三方零件，所以他们只是在利用人们获利，因为我们被困住了，对吧？我们陷入了这种困境。所以这是一个恶性循环。所以，罗曼，既然我已经和你讨论了“烂化”的问题，你现在的愤怒程度在哪里？让我们定在九分。我是九分。
Like I'm ready to just like go to the next room, yank that smart thermostat out of my wall and just put in an old-fashioned honeywell analog dial. Roman, I feel your pain and I have some good news. We are going to bring your anger level down a little bit, hopefully, because there are people who are trying to make things better. There are people fighting back and trying to outlaw this form of inshittification. Excellent. Okay.
就像我准备直接去隔壁房间，把那个智能恒温器从墙上拽下来，换上一个老式的霍尼韦尔模拟拨盘。罗曼，我感同身受，我有一些好消息。我们要稍微降低一下你的愤怒程度，希望如此，因为有些人正在努力让事情变得更好。有些人正在反击，试图取缔这种形式的“烂化”。太棒了。好的。
Let's talk about that after the brain. So we're back with Chris Barubei talking about inshittification. Yes, Roman. So let's talk about some of the people who are trying to fight back against, you know, these big companies who are locking you in, trying to profit off your bad experiences, right? And there are a couple of ways people are fighting this. So there's kind of the dodgy, questionable, maybe outside of the bounds of the law way. And then there's the law-abiding citizen.
我们在休息后谈谈那个。所以我们回到克里斯·巴鲁贝谈论“烂化”。是的，罗曼。那么让我们谈谈一些试图反击的人，你知道，这些锁定你、试图从你的糟糕体验中获利的大公司，对吧？人们有几种反击方式。所以有一种是狡猾的、有问题的、可能在法律界限之外的方式。还有一种是守法公民。
I want to do everything by the book way. So where do you want to start with this? Well, I definitely want to start with the dodgy questionable outside of the law way. That sounds way more fun. So Corey Docter says we're now seeing a lot of black market or kind of gray market efforts to fix this problem, right? We're seeing people hacking software in an iPhone, for example, and making it work with third-party applications, right? When you do that with an Apple product, that is called jailbreaking. But people aren't just doing it with Apple products.
我想一切都按部就班的方式。那么你想从哪里开始？嗯，我绝对想从那个狡猾的、有问题的、法律之外的方式开始。那听起来有趣多了。所以科里·多克托罗说我们现在看到很多黑市或某种灰色市场的努力来解决这个问题，对吧？我们看到人们在破解iPhone里的软件，例如，让它与第三方应用程序一起工作，对吧？当你对苹果产品这样做时，这被称为越狱。但人们不仅仅在苹果产品上这样做。
They're doing it with all kinds of tech now. And if you're like a board grad student with an electron tunneling microscope, you can just like have at it, right? Lots and lots of these softwares have been broken into it. It's actually pretty easy for someone who has, you know, hacker skills and experience. And obviously this kind of solution, hacking into the software, like, it is not something the company wants you to do. I don't think I need to say that. Your user agreement usually says, I will not do something like this. But it is becoming more and more common.
他们现在在各种技术上都这样做。如果你像一个拥有电子隧道显微镜的无聊研究生，你可以直接动手，对吧？很多很多这样的软件已经被破解了。对于拥有黑客技能和经验的人来说，这实际上相当容易。显然，这种解决方案，破解软件，这不是公司希望你做的事情。我想我不需要说出来。你的用户协议通常说，我不会做这样的事情。但它正变得越来越普遍。
And our farmer Jared, he told me, he's actually seen this kind of thing pretty often in his day-to-day life, like being used by repair people. There have been a lot of black market things that have been released that independent providers are using. laptops from China that have cracked John Deere software on it. So I'm completely on board with fixing this problem. However, you need to fix it. But I do think that there's probably a little room to be cautious if you do not know where the software or hardware that you're using to fix the problem came from. Yeah, it does sound sketchy. And Jared on our call, he made clear to me he has never used this kind of technology because, you know, he wants to follow the rules.
我们的农民贾里德告诉我，他实际上在日常生活中经常看到这种事情，比如被维修人员使用。已经发布了很多黑市的东西，独立供应商正在使用。带有破解的约翰迪尔软件的笔记本电脑。所以我完全支持解决这个问题。然而，无论你如何解决它。但我确实认为，如果你不知道你用来解决问题的软件或硬件来自哪里，可能还是有一点谨慎的余地。是的，听起来确实很可疑。贾里德在我们的通话中向我明确表示，他从未使用过这种技术，因为，你知道，他想遵守规则。
And also, you don't actually know what you're putting on your computer when you are working with this. kind of thing. So if something goes wrong, you know, you can't call John Deere because at this point, you are doing something you're not supposed to be doing. Create some hesitation in using technology like that on your hundreds of thousands of dollars worth of machines because you're out of any ecosystem that can help you because you're operating outside of the margins. So on top of that, Corey Doctor says that in a lot of cases, this kind of solution, this hackery solution is probably illegal. Well, that just drives me crazy. So why is it illegal? Well, there is something called a digital lock that is on a lot of these things. And it's a very particular kind of software. Back in the late 90s, early 2000s, there was concern about ripping DVDs and music piracy, stuff like that. So back then, record companies and movie studios,
而且，当你处理这种事情时，你实际上并不知道你在计算机上安装了什么。所以如果出了问题，你知道，你不能给约翰迪尔打电话，因为在这一点上，你正在做你不应该做的事情。在价值数十万美元的机器上使用这种技术会产生一些犹豫，因为你脱离了任何可以帮助你的生态系统，因为你在边缘之外操作。最重要的是，科里·多克托罗说，在很多情况下，这种解决方案，这种黑客解决方案可能是非法的。好吧，那真是让我抓狂。那为什么它是非法的？嗯，有一种叫做数字锁的东西在很多这些东西上。这是一种非常特殊的软件。在90年代末、2000年代初，人们担心翻录DVD和音乐盗版之类的事情。所以那时，唱片公司和电影制片厂，
they added digital locks to their files. And in 1998, the U.S. passed a law that made it illegal to break a digital lock. They passed a law called the Digital Millennium Copyright Act. in Section 1201, it says it is a felony punishable by a five-year prison sentence and a $500,000 fine to tamper with or expose weaknesses in or discuss weaknesses of a digital lock. And now, this law that was designed for MP3 sharing, it is now being applied to all of these other devices that we use every day. Five years in prison. There should be a prison sentence for passing that law. Well, Roman, I think you may have to take that one up with both parties in Congress in 1998. Yeah, no, I know.
他们在文件中添加了数字锁。1998年，美国通过了一项法律，规定破坏数字锁是非法的。他们通过了一项名为《数字千年版权法》（DMCA）的法律。在第1201节中，它说篡改、暴露弱点或讨论数字锁的弱点是重罪，可判处五年监禁和50万美元罚款。现在，这项为MP3共享而设计的法律，现在正被应用于我们每天使用的所有其他设备上。五年监禁。通过那项法律的人应该被判刑。好吧，罗曼，我想你可能得在1998年和国会的两党去谈谈那个。是的，不，我知道。
There's everyone's at fault for that one. So as you can tell, the sketchy solution, you know, it has some problems. Obviously, they're not enforcing this law too often, but it's still a thing that exists that is out there. So they have that option to do that if they catch you with this kind of software. So this is kind of the hacker path, the solving and certification, but is there a more law-abiding path? Okay. So in the past couple years, there has been a movement to pass laws that would limit the power of these big companies, right? and to make sure that as a consumer, we have more ownership over our stuff.
每个人都要为那个负责。所以正如你所看到的，那个狡猾的解决方案，你知道，它有一些问题。显然，他们不会太频繁地执行这项法律，但它仍然是一个存在的东西。所以如果他们抓到你使用这种软件，他们有权这样做。所以这就是黑客路径，解决“烂化”的方法，但有没有更守法的路径？好的。在过去几年里，出现了一场运动，旨在通过法律来限制这些大公司的权力，对吧？并确保作为消费者，我们对我们的东西有更多的所有权。
So this is part of a movement that is called the Right to Repair. So the Right to Repair Movement, it basically says everybody should have the right to fix their own stuff. It's right there in the name. It is in the name. Good name. It's a good name. It's very descriptive. And one of the leaders of this movement is a woman named Gay Gordon-Burne.
所以这是被称为“维修权”（Right to Repair）运动的一部分。所以维修权运动，它基本上说每个人都应该有权修理自己的东西。它就在名字里。它确实在名字里。好名字。这是一个好名字。它非常具有描述性。这场运动的领导者之一是一位名叫盖伊·戈登-伯恩（Gay Gordon-Byrne）的女性。
She has a lot of public speaking about this subject, including a TED Talk that now has two and a half million views. I am a repair geek. I grew up fixing things with my dad. It was what we did. We fixed our TV. We fixed our refrigerator. We fixed stuff that didn't need fixing. Gay Gordon-Burn is the head of this group called the Repair Association.
她在这个主题上有很多公开演讲，包括一个现在有250万次观看的TED演讲。我是一个维修极客。我从小就和我爸爸一起修理东西。这就是我们所做的。我们修理电视。我们修理冰箱。我们修理那些不需要修理的东西。盖伊·戈登-伯恩是这个名为“维修协会”（Repair Association）的组织的负责人。
And their argument is, look, if we truly own something, we should be able to fix it. What's really got me irritated is that at this point, the vast majority of products on the market today cannot be repaired by any party without being totally dependent on the manufacturer. And the day the manufacturer decides they don't want you to fix it, it's over. This is a completely artificial problem.
他们的论点是，看，如果我们真正拥有某样东西，我们就应该能够修理它。真正让我恼火的是，在这一点上，当今市场上绝大多数产品在没有完全依赖制造商的情况下，任何一方都无法修理。而制造商决定不让你修理的那一天，一切就结束了。这是一个完全人为的问题。
And this argument has picked up a lot of followers. There are people fighting for this in Europe, in South America, and actually one of the people out there advocating for it pretty loudly is our farmer, Jared Wilson. You know, I've been to Washington a few years. times and spoken with staff from senators and representatives. So, you know, not really trying to make anything political, just sharing my experiences with the people who are elected to pass laws to govern how things work in this country. Okay, well, I want to know. So is there been
这个论点吸引了很多追随者。在欧洲、南美都有人为之奋斗，实际上，大声疾呼的人之一就是我们的农民贾里德·威尔逊。你知道，我去过华盛顿几次，和参议员及众议员的工作人员谈过。所以，你知道，并不是真的想让任何事情政治化，只是分享我的经历，与那些被选出来通过法律来管理这个国家运作方式的人分享。好的，好吧，我想知道。那么有任何成功吗？因为这看起来像是一场艰苦的战斗。实际上，过去几年它相当成功。看到这场运动的发展令人惊喜。特别是在欧洲，这方面有很多进展。所以2024年，欧盟通过了一项指令，规定每个成员国必须在2026年夏天之前拥有维修权法，所以就是即将到来的这个夏天。这将要求制造商为所有家用电器提供维修，包括洗衣机，甚至智能手机。所以很快，我们将对它在欧洲的实施情况有一个很好的了解。但在美国，也有一些进展。所以几个
any success with this? Because this seems like an uphill battle. Actually, it has been pretty successful the last couple of years. And it's been pleasantly surprising to see this movement developing. Europe specifically, there has been a lot of movement on this. So in 2024, the European Union passed a directive saying every member state needed to have a right to repair law by the summer of 2026, so that is this coming summer. And that will require manufacturers to offer repairs for all household appliances, including washing machines, even smartphones. So pretty soon, we'll have a pretty good idea of how that's being implemented in Europe. But in the United States, there's been some movement as well. So a few.
几个州现在已经通过了维修权法。科罗拉多州在2023年通过了一项法律，规定农民必须拥有维修权。俄勒冈州通过了一项涵盖电子和电动轮椅的法律。我们谈到了一点轮椅用户，你知道，他们需要获得维修工具，因为他们面临的市场很小，修理东西的费用很高。现在相当多的州已经通过了关于修理手机和笔记本电脑的法律。这包括那些在商业利益方面相当友好的州。我们的州维修权法案正在取得进展。所以它真的进展得很顺利，包括德克萨斯州，包括那些被认为对大企业相当友好的立法机构，仍然在通过维修法。
few states have now passed right to repair laws. Colorado passed a law in 2023, saying that farmers need to have the right to repair. Oregon passed a law covering electronic and powered wheelchairs. We talked a little bit about wheelchair users, you know, they need access to repair tools because they're facing a pretty small market, pretty high rates for getting stuff fixed. And now quite a few states have passed laws about fixing phones and laptops. And that includes states who are otherwise pretty friendly to business interests. We're getting somewhere with these state right to repair bills. So it's really going well, including Texas, including legislatures that have, you know, consider pretty friendly to big business, are still passing repair laws.
目前已有少数几个州通过了“维修权”法案。科罗拉多州在2023年通过了一项法律，规定农民必须拥有维修权。俄勒冈州通过了一项涵盖电子轮椅和电动轮椅的法律。我们之前简单讨论过轮椅使用者，他们需要使用维修工具，因为他们面临的市场规模很小，维修费用也非常高。现在，相当多的州已经通过了关于维修手机和笔记本电脑的法律。这其中也包括那些通常对商业利益比较友好的州。我们在这些州的维修权法案上取得了一些进展。所以进展确实很顺利，甚至包括德克萨斯州在内，那些被认为对大企业非常友好的立法机构也正在通过维修法案。
It's great. So the latest development in all of this is a national right to repair bill for cars that is under consideration in the House of Representatives. That bill is bipartisan, by the way. It has been sponsored by Republicans and Democrats. It reflects something from Stein's law. which is a law of finance that says that anything that can't go on forever eventually stops. And I think that people are fed up. And so we're getting some repair bills.
太棒了。目前关于这一切的最新进展是众议院正在审议一项全国性的汽车维修权法案。顺便说一下，该法案是两党共同支持的。它由共和党人和民主党人共同发起。这反映了斯坦定律中的某些内容，这是一条金融定律，即任何不能永远持续下去的事情最终都会停止。我认为人们已经受够了。所以我们正在获得一些维修法案。
It's very hard to be on the wrong side of repair and saying you shouldn't be allowed to fix your own stuff. So this all seems like good news. So there are some laws that might reverse and certification. It is good news. And actually in response to this push, we have already seen some companies who have started sending out these repair tools. So these are companies trying to get out preemptively ahead of these laws. I bet. And an example of this, a couple of years ago, a little company called John Deere, perhaps you have heard of them from multiple references in this story.
站在维修的对立面，说你不应该被允许修理自己的东西，这很难。所以这一切看起来都是好消息。因此，有一些法律可能会扭转这种局面。这确实是好消息。事实上，为了应对这种推动，我们已经看到一些公司开始分发这些维修工具。所以这些公司正试图在这些法律出台之前先发制人。我敢打赌。一个例子是，几年前，一家名为约翰迪尔的小公司，也许你在这个故事的多个参考资料中听说过他们。
A little company called John Deere have put out this software to their customers that's designed to make it possible for farmers to decode these error messages and troubleshoot lots of problems with their tractors. So to fix things themselves. And as of this year, John Deere told me, farmers can actually. override a derating in some cases. So this is the problem we talked about at the beginning of the show where the tractor shuts itself down. So this all sounds like good news. But there are still some caveats. Okay. So what is this caveat? Well, Jared says there are still flaws with the repair software. He's particularly concerned about the way it collects his data, his harvesting data. He says that's not ideal for him. He's actually been part of a class action lawsuit against John Deere saying they have an
一家名为约翰迪尔的小公司向他们的客户发布了这款软件，旨在让农民能够解码这些错误信息并排除拖拉机的许多故障。也就是让他们自己修理东西。截至今年，约翰迪尔告诉我，农民在某些情况下实际上可以覆盖降级设置。这就是我们在节目开始时谈到的问题，即拖拉机自行关闭。所以这一切听起来都是好消息。但仍然存在一些警告。好吧。那么这个警告是什么呢？嗯，贾里德说维修软件仍然存在缺陷。他特别担心它收集他的数据，即他的收获数据的方式。他说这对他说并不理想。他实际上参与了一起针对约翰迪尔的集体诉讼，称他们有
unfair monopoly on repair tools, and the software is part of the complaints that they filed. And in a bigger sense, while there's been progress around right to repair, there's no guarantee that things like the federal law about car repairs is going to pass, right? Like, there are some big lobbies pushing back against that. Some car companies have opposed more right to repair laws because they worry it could lead to their intellectual property being violated. My God. Their intellectual property about the information on my car.
对维修工具的不公平垄断，而该软件就是他们投诉的一部分。从更广泛的意义上讲，虽然在维修权方面取得了进展，但不能保证像联邦汽车维修法这样的事情会通过，对吧？比如，有一些大型游说团体在反对这一点。一些汽车公司反对更多的维修权法律，因为他们担心这会导致他们的知识产权受到侵犯。天哪。关于我车上信息的知识产权。
That is an absurd assertion. Yeah, I mean, when you put it that way, it sounds pretty silly. But these right to repair laws, like, they can make a big difference, right? But they aren't a magic bullet. Like, many of these laws do not outlaw parts pairing, for example, so they don't solve the problem of interoperability. You know, you can't necessarily put third-party parts on to repair something. So there's an argument that these laws could go further. Yeah.
这是一个荒谬的主张。是的，我的意思是，当你这样说时，听起来很傻。但这些维修权法律，它们可以带来很大的不同，对吧？但它们不是灵丹妙药。比如，许多这些法律并没有禁止零件配对，例如，所以它们没有解决互操作性的问题。你知道，你不一定能安装第三方零件来修理东西。所以有一种观点认为这些法律可以走得更远。是的。
So it can make the platform better, but you're still locked into the platform. You're totally locked into the platform. So in lots of ways, like, you need these laws to be more comprehensive. And Corey Doctro says, like, maybe we should start thinking beyond the laws. Like, he has other approaches to this. He thinks we actually need to be doing something a lot more radical. Oh, okay. Tell me more.
所以它可以让平台变得更好，但你仍然被锁定在平台中。你完全被锁定在平台中。所以在很多方面，你需要这些法律更加全面。科里·多克托罗说，也许我们应该开始超越法律思考。他对此有其他方法。他认为我们实际上需要做一些更激进的事情。哦，好的。多告诉我一些。
What does he have in mind? One thing Corey is pushing for is countries outside the United States to basically break the digital locks, right? To allow third-party manufacturers to make replacement parts, things like that. So Canada and Mexico are in a trade war with the U.S. right now. And Corey says, look, what if those countries made generic replacement parts that go around the locks and then export those generic parts all over the world? We could do the same for tractors and tractor parts and cars and car parts. We have all the car part factories in Ontario, right? If we can't ship those across the border anymore, we can just make generic car parts in Ontario,
他有什么想法？科里正在推动的一件事是让美国以外的国家基本上打破数字锁，对吧？允许第三方制造商制造替换零件，诸如此类。所以加拿大和墨西哥目前正与美国进行贸易战。科里说，看，如果这些国家制造绕过锁的通用替换零件，然后把这些通用零件出口到全世界会怎样？我们可以对拖拉机、拖拉机零件、汽车和汽车零件做同样的事情。我们在安大略省拥有所有的汽车零件工厂，对吧？如果我们不能再把它们运过边境，我们就可以在安大略省制造通用汽车零件，
sell them all over the world along with the software to turn off the car part checking tool in the cars. We could have third-party ink manufacturing. And you know what? What if we don't do it? Someone else is going to do it. It is a very cori-doctoro thing to turn Canada into a lawless land of jailbreaking. But I do love it. I don't see it ever really happening in that way, but I do love it. Yeah, that can feel like a long shot, right?
把它们卖到全世界，并附带关闭汽车零件检查工具的软件。我们可以有第三方墨水制造。你知道吗？如果我们不做呢？别人也会做。把加拿大变成一个越狱的无法无天之地是非常科里·多克托罗式的做法。但我确实喜欢它。我不认为它会以那种方式真正发生，但我确实喜欢它。是的，这感觉像是一个遥不可及的目标，对吧？
But we do have to think about different ways to fix this problem. I totally agree. Roman, there's so much going on in the world right now. But this issue feels pretty urgent to me. Because if we don't act, you know, if we don't do something about, about these kind of everyday frustrations, this general shittiness of things, but also this big cost for lots of people,
但我们确实必须考虑解决这个问题的不同方法。我完全同意。罗曼，现在世界上发生了很多事情。但这个问题对我来说感觉相当紧迫。因为如果我们不采取行动，你知道，如果我们不对这些日常的挫折，这种普遍的糟糕状况，以及对许多人来说的巨大成本做点什么，
it's just going to get worse. And on a much simpler level, Roman, I would like to live in a world where somebody like Jared can just fix his tractor. It doesn't benefit us, the citizen, to have stuff that we buy that we can't fix when it breaks. It's not good economically.
情况只会变得更糟。而且在一个更简单的层面上，罗曼，我想生活在一个像贾里德这样的人可以修理他的拖拉机的地方。购买我们无法修理的东西对我们公民没有好处。从经济上讲，这不好。
It's not good environmentally. allowing these companies to stymie competition is not in our best interest. And I really hope that people can take that to heart. Well, amen to that. Thank you, Chris. Even in my incandescent anger, I'm having fun with this story. I appreciate it. Oh, good.
从环境上讲，这也不好。允许这些公司阻碍竞争不符合我们的最大利益。我真的希望人们能把这一点放在心上。好吧，阿门。谢谢你，克里斯。即使在我炽热的愤怒中，我也在享受这个故事。我很感激。哦，太好了。
Okay, so this was infuriating but also entertaining. That's what I was going for today. Exactly. Like good punk rock. That's the first time I've ever been compared to good punk rock. So thank you for that. In April 2026, as we were finishing this episode, John Deere agreed to pay $99 million to settle the class action lawsuit about right to repair concerns. Jared Wilson, the farmer from our episode, was part of that lawsuit.
好吧，这令人愤怒，但也很有趣。这就是我今天想要达到的效果。没错。就像好的朋克摇滚。这是我第一次被比作好的朋克摇滚。所以谢谢你。2026年4月，当我们完成这一集时，约翰迪尔同意支付9900万美元来和解关于维修权担忧的集体诉讼。我们节目中的农民贾里德·威尔逊参与了那场诉讼。
We reached out to John Deere to discuss claims made in the story. In response, they sent us information about their consumer repair software. And John Deere told us that they estimate there are third-party replacement parts for about 60% of all jobs. John Deere parts on the market today. We also reached out to Apple. A representative told us that Apple supports third-party replacement parts except in cases where there are security concerns. Apple also told us they have recently expanded access to their repair tools for consumers
我们联系了约翰迪尔，讨论故事中提出的主张。作为回应，他们向我们发送了关于其消费者维修软件的信息。约翰迪尔告诉我们，他们估计目前市场上约60%的约翰迪尔零件有第三方替换零件。我们还联系了苹果公司。一位代表告诉我们，苹果支持第三方替换零件，除非涉及安全问题。苹果还告诉我们，他们最近扩大了消费者对其维修工具的访问权限，
and have a recycling take-back program in most countries that sell Apple products. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Barubei, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, fact-checking by Graham Hesha, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real, and Dorian. George Langford. Corey Doctor's latest book is called Inchidification, why everything suddenly got worse and what to do about it. It is super fun and infuriating, but mostly fun. You can find it wherever you buy books. Special thanks this week to Nathan Proctor at the PIRG.
并在大多数销售苹果产品的国家设有回收计划。本周的《99%隐形》由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑，格雷厄姆·赫沙事实核查，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·里尔和多里安·乔治·兰福德配乐。科里·多克托罗的最新书名为《垃圾化：为什么一切突然变糟以及该怎么办》。它超级有趣且令人愤怒，但主要是很有趣。你可以在任何买书的地方找到它。本周特别感谢PIRG的内森·普罗克特。
Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Delaney Hall is a senior editor. Kurt Colstett is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashamadon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California.
凯西·2是我们的执行制片人。德莱尼·霍尔是高级编辑。库尔特·科尔斯特特是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括杰森·德莱昂、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、拉沙马顿、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心。
You can find us on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server. You can find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. I don't know. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Blue Sky以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。你可以在99PI.org找到该链接以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。我不知道。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。